allora ascoltavi scommesse di mutande
sotto possiamo farla sempre facciamo che
mi vesto da solo e mi va bene però
viventi prendendo buon serve amici siamo
se non aveva la registrazione un casino
può alzare gli amici siamo tornati su
htc by sporche oggi cercheremo di
tagliare un po di frutta procede tutti
fruit ninja col gioco che andava un
sacco quando avevate fosse prima in
fondo lo ricordate vostro prima i phone
o quello che che portava da scuola se lo
ricorda bene non so se vi ricordate ma
quando taglia watt e la frutta la cava
da morire perché vostro iphone un po
faceva schifo e adesso hanno inventato
quello vr quindi 8 spadaccini alla mano
si dice bocchino amico giampiero la
spada me la dia
la ringrazio metti mai che un punto io
la prendo perché bellissimo che vede la
metto qui sembra fontana no kat
allora della metro qua è là beh allora
basta alla malattia classica se però le
fruttano logico cosa faccio lancio
mi scusi eh allora invito avvicina
perché qua becco qualcuno allora io devo
affettare la frutta va bene allora
ragazzi questo gioco molto tra quella
non doveva affittarla secondo me però
questo gioco molto tranquillo non so se
lo ricorda non è tranquilla me lo
ricordavo ma ha però con una zampata
sola fine fai più punti fi giusto
si era così sul telefono è ma non me lo
ricordo
faccio schifo gioco va bene la sentite
cambiamo gioco perché io non so se tar
la frutta non sono capaci la frutta non
la mangio maggio vitamine le vitamine le
prendo dal sole solo una cagata
non è come il live sé perché le spade
sono lunghissime riavvicinare proprio al
cibo capitoli avvicinare questi
pretendono più mi avvicini che usi le
mie gambe
tra l'altro ragazzi siccome il file non
è mio tutti questi giochi che sto
giocando questi giorni gli ho comprati a
giampiero e sto giocando dall'account di
giampiero quindi prego io ti sto
comprato la casacca laida faccio
veramente schifo nel caso lo stesse
chiedendo perché non prendo la frutta
manca a pagarla però secondo me però io
dovrei essere molto più in alto di
questo punto non c'è un modo per alzare
il pavimento
infine alzerà il pavimento di non so
perché sì che i muoverà ho perso sì una
sega 99 punti è veramente basso dunque
vorrei analizzare il posto è veramente
bellissima poi affettare la frutta che
già a terra aspetta la posso anche
prendere mannaia il cocco il cocco oggi
diventa si è bellissimo possa prendere
la frutta a terra porca vacca è peggio
che andar sushi ma stiamo già posso
farlo devo prenderò mangiar me lo devo
riuscire a portarle alla bocca e
difficilissimo ma facciamo un'altra
partita poi appena finire a quella
proverò a raccogliere il cibo la terra
non è difficilissimo di più
l'ex co ma come mai si è ancora in
mutande senti io cado questa roba lame a
puoi cambiare le lame pro
ma che dice bellissimo tutto candito a
una lama puoi cambiare per cambiare
l'altra è fantastico cioè un solo anno
candito a destra e con la norma la
sinistra a quella pensava più lunga però
ora mettiamo entrambe consiste infatti
sotto cibo ma queste non tagliano ma non
tagliano a rotaia a perché se le prendi
di lato non tagliano ma sto male e tipo
un lightsaber molto più con vitamine e
molto più light fatto più light novel
questo molto fatto veramente schifo
proprio queste forse riesco a prendere
il cibo termi tutti dai no flyzone ce
l'ho fatta ci ho messo una vita faceva
parte sotto bellissimo che è veramente
difficile prendere il cibo per terra
però ce la puoi fare se te lo lanci
direttamente nell'esofago se li prendi
dalla parte della lama piatta non di
nuovi tagli e quindi vai via a bilanci
di è fighissimo come game over ragazzi
veramente difficile giuro sono
esattamente dietro dottor fetus che
peccato
cioè io ho fatto 99
il primo nel mondo ha fatto 52.190 due
macro stiamo dicendo impossibile è stato
tutto sei giorni su sto gioco immagini
ma comunque starà a me mi fanno schifo
tagliano non tagliano niente tagliano
per finta comunque un gioco veramente
figo e ve lo dico rilassa se non
riuscissero states randomicamente visto
che sto prendendo tutta la frutta tranne
quella che dovrei prendere vorrei
cambiare le lame queste mi fanno schifo
per quanto siano lunghe non tagliano
cambiamola ma se metto quelle di prima
non ne farei nulla vorrei sbloccare
anche le altre per vedere come sono
parte però non ci sono un po sfide
queste per file questo vediamo allora
abbandona allora abbiamo la modalità
arcade aree sopravvivenza
what c'è un tizio adesso del capiamoci
un attimo ha sì ma c'è uno che mi
sparate le robe prima che me ne spara
tante come dovrei tagliare la frutta
tutto con la rinuncia è tanta non so se
capito cavallo ho preso un mango in
faccia lo sapevi no mango io chiedo
aiuto a giampiero è assolutamente né di
dire sì no devi dire assolutamente sì
che amico se lei non capire comunque la
e non ha capito cos'è sto tizio però ci
riprovo perché mi piace forse devo
ottenere la lama così tipo i samurai zen
che mi arrivano in faccia no non devo
tenere la cosa simile non so come
colpire tutte la sigo ma perché è però è
difficilissimo il gioco più difficile
che abbia mai fatto cioè che domani in
confronto è una cagata abbandona prima a
fare un'altra modalità questa che mi
spara mi mette l'ansia arcade che io non
ho mai provata
sessanta secondi l'erc a questa la
modalità che gioca via alla sull'iphone
dove facevi dove c'erano le banane
quelle blu capito al posto di fare una
telefonata
essi però io non mi hai fatto male amati
infatti faccio youtube maledizione è
comunque sono movimenti che si insegnano
anche nei templi antichi li ha quindi tu
guadagni tempo in base a quanto colpisce
ma stai scherzando questo è un gioco si
siano un po di frutta gianpi se il cielo
a te lo giuro via in cascata la la
cuffia ma non fa niente
sta anche un ninja sordo vince non ho
avuto un attacco epilettico stanno
arrivando delle fratte tu non lo vedi
mandati che così lista modalità faccio
un sacco di punti non fatti 459 e ti
sfido a fare di meglio
mi sfidi ti sfido a fare di meglio dopo
lo fai tu le faccio ancora una volta
questa perché veramente [ __ ] poi mi
trovo bene riprova vado sono carico sono
pronto
le slot pu ho fissato tutto però ho
fissato fa un freddo boia dal chiave
vocal dr.d ad avere freddo da un
cappotto perché niente 1 detto prendendo
tank a licola roba che non ha idea mi
sembra essere il mercato della frutta di
domenica mattina alle 6 fighissimo o
questo è un gioco maledizione questo il
nome dal gear quelle robe lì da konami
valeri questa faccio veramente un sacco
di punti nelle altre far ciò kagari
questo sono bravissimo infatti ti sfido
devi fare arcade dopo 736 tempo scaduto
ma la mia anima noto 300 500 c a bonus
841 o record di queste sono dieci volte
il mio punteggio quindi niente male
riproviamoci e dopo proprio mi si è
aperto il menu in mano però posso vedere
la frutta p da vicino io andrei a vedere
l'interno della frutta così vi spiego
come sono fatte le proprietà vitaminiche
allora questo mango ho sempre desiderato
essere dalla parte della frutta di fruit
ninja così da farmi tagliare però non
c'è nessuno che taglia quindi vado io 9
b mamma mia
occhio perché ha paura di prenderti
faccia inferti numeri sono abbastanza
lontano lo è
mi sa che ho fatto meno di prima però è
stato molto figo 55 646 fatto cagare
stavolta 1841 niente male direi che poi
provare tutto quello che veramente figo
per oggi mi improvviso cameraman
non ho mai fatto questa cosa
allora ragazzi prima di tutto vorrei
dire mi dispiace smontare il vostro
idolo lorenzo cristiane adesso che devo
battere il suo record guidate umiliato
davanti a tutti però insomma no no
aspetta però non vado mai visto ti
sembrava facile andare inizio volta amen
e sembrano veramente ok allora parliamo
tutta la prima partita che ci sono in
questo video che se faceva veramente
così non può andare bene e filomeno
babbo mio dio ma tutto è comunque ci
sono molti di più io ma è bellissimo se
a volte romagna macedonia troppo bello
una ragazza è un'esplosione di colori ma
è che sanno di vita più bella perché
l'aria 43 non ne capiamo il clock se no
non ho preso mi sbaglio 91 l'argomento
non è competitiva
mamma mia guarda che bello non ho e la
brutta fine tricolori no no è la russa
fini altri colori che richiamano bene se
no il battere ingegnere quel broccolo di
due è troppo rumore
sì sì purtroppo troppe dry vedrà in poi
battere
sembra che c'è una precisa ancora
gigante nella stanza e sedentario
no no no questa parte aiutino a in
futuro da visita comunque se l'ho
battuto
no non è vero soprattutto no però alti 6
conti 6 a 700 che schifo ma vincere
una vita sociale donne che avevano
capito qual è il mio come lavoro che
devo fare
basta quindi a molto sottacendo non ci
credo
basta un'ora in avanti questa partita la
data guarda qua ai quasi mille no al
prezzo di punti perché no
1072 hai vinto una scheda grafica nvidia
complimento bravissimo va bene ragazzi
io lascio il canale a chi ne può
usufruire meglio ciao ragazzi ci vediamo
al prossimo video ecco perché è allora
semplice come previsto fiscale effetto
con ci sei ok se non si dà con gli
scritti stivati che procediamo ad un
prossimo video bel ragazzo aspetto
[Musica]